ZDF heute live herzlich willkommen zu
unserem Ukraine Update in dieser Woche
die schweren Kämpfe im Süden und im
Osten der Ukraine dauern an und gestern
meldete der ukrainische Innenminister
Klimenko russische Angriffe auf mehr als
100 Orte innerhalb von 24 Stunden es
sein die heftigsten Angriffe seit
Jahresbeginn gewesen besonders umkämpft
ist weiter die Stadt avdwka im Osten der
Ukraine dort versuchen die russischen
Streitkräfte unter erheblichen Verlusten
die Stadt
einzukesseln gleichzeitig soll die
ukrainische Armee Panzer vom Süden in
die Ostukraine verlegen anstatt die
Gegenoffensive zu unterstützen wir
wollen heute fragen wo steht dieser
Krieg aktuell droht möglicherweise ein
Stellungskrieg und welche Erfolge konnte
die Gegenoffensive tatsächlich erreichen
und wie könnten die kommenden Monate in
der Ukraine Aussehen darüber spreche ich
gleich mit der militärxper ftin Claudia
Major von der Stiftung Wissenschaft und
Politik und wir schalten gleich zu
meinem Kollegen daran Hassan Sade der
heute in kupjansk nah der Front im
Nordosten der Ukraine unterwegs war auch
dort wächst der Druck durch Putins
Truppen eure Fragen und Gedanken zum
Thema könnt ihr wie immer gerne direkt
im Chat stellen oder ihr schickt sie uns
per Mail an die Mailadresse die ihr seht
zdfheute-live@zdf.de und ich versuche
dann so viele wie möglich davon hier im
Stream unterzubringen bevor ich jetzt
gleich mit Frau major spreche hat mein
Kollege Jonas Kapp einmal die Lage an
den frontgebieten
zusammengefasst das ist auch ein Krieg
der Bilder ist wird wieder deutlich
diese russischen Aufnahmen sollen zeigen
wie eine Drohne einen ukrainischen
Panzer in der Region sporisia an der
Südfront zerstört das sagt das russische
Verteidigungsministerium es soll sich um
ein leopardpanzer aus deutscher
Produktion handeln auch in der
Ostukraine gibt es weiter heftige
Gefechte besonders schwer umkämpft ist
die Stadt afdk in der Region Donetzk
diese Bilder veröffentlicht von
ukrainischer Seite sollen den Angriff
auf eine russische panzerkolonne zeigen
rund um afdifk bündeln die Russen ihre
Kräfte sie müssen offenbar herbe
Verluste einstecken der ukrainische
Soldat Alexander fasst die russische
Taktik so
zusammen die Soldaten kommen in Wellen
sie werden nach vorne geschickt und dann
umgebracht dann kommen neue sie können
es sich
leisten nicht nur die große Zahl der
russischen Soldaten stellt die Ukraine
vor Probleme auch die materielle
Überlegenheit der Russen wirkt sich
spürbar
aus sie haben mehr Ressourcen mehr
Munition wenn wir so viel Munition
hätten könnten wir besser kämpfen aber
wir haben diese Option nicht also müssen
wir mit dem zurecht kommen was wir
haben laut ukrainischeem Militär werden
jetzt Panzer nach afdfka verlegt
offenbar von der
Südfront ja wie sind diese Bilder
einzuordnen darüber spreche ich jetzt
mit Claudia major sie ist Sicherheits
und militärexpertin bei der Stiftung
Wissenschaft und Politik in Berlin hallo
Frau major guten Abend also wir sehen
Panzer die offenbar vom Süden in die
Ostukraine verlegt werden ihre
Einschätzung nach was passiert da gerade
was für gerade sehen erinnert zu großen
Teilen an die Schlacht um bachmut also
das Russland mit einem extrem hohen
Einsatz von Soldaten also von Menschen
und von Ausrüstung versucht diese
einzunehmen und obwohl sie da so viel
Personal und Material immer wieder an
die Front schicken gelingt es ihn
dennoch nicht diese Stadt einzunehmen
von der Stadt vergleichbar wie bachmut
steht nicht mehr viel aber sie versuchen
es trotzdem und die Ukraine ist deswegen
es geht ja zeigen auch die Bilder die
sie gerade eben gezeigt haben die
Ukraine ist deswegen gezwungen auch
Material dthin zu verlegen um die
Verteidigung aufrecht zu erhalten die
sagen die Ukraine ist gezwungen dorthin
auch Material zu verlegen ist aus ihrer
Sicht da auch eine Strategie der
ukrainischen Streitkräfte zu
erkennen wenn die Stadt auf diefk fallen
würde würden beispielsweise auch würde
sich das auch auf die Reichweite ähm der
ukrainischen Streitkräfte auswirken das
heißt Sie hätten weniger Chancen auch
noch weiter hinter die russischen Linien
zu zielen
also es wäre auf jeden Fall ein Verlust
für die ukrainischen Streitkräfte und
den wollen sie natürlich verhindern
afdka ist seit 2014 sehr stark ausgebaut
worden sehr stark befestigt worden ähm
das heißt die ukrainischen Streitkräfte
haben dort prinzipiell erstmal bessere
Voraussetzungen als an anderen
Orten die Stadt avdivka wird seit
Monaten heftig gekämpft sie ist
gewissermaßen zu einem Symbol des
ukrainischen Widerstandes geworden warum
ist avdivka denn aus russischer Sicht so
bedeutend warum wird gerade versucht D
mit so einem so heftigen Einsatz von
Material und von Personen von Soldaten
diese Stadt
einzukesseln weil es gewissermaßen auch
einen einen einen Tor oder ein
strategischer Punkt ist von dem die
Ukraine immer wieder weit was ich eben
sagte weit hinter die russischen Linien
zielen kann wenn der diefg eingenommen
ist verbessert sich de facto für für die
russischen Streitkräfte die Lage im
Hinterland und das ist einer der Gründe
warum sie so sehr auf afdevka
abzielen wir hören jetzt dass die
russischen Streitkräfte dort eben 40.000
Soldaten
zusammenziehen offenbar hat die Führung
nimmt die Führung dabei auch erhebliche
Verluste in Kauf eben vor allem von
Daten welche Strategie ist für sie darin
zu erkennen ist darin eine Strategie zu
erkennen ich glaube es ist wichtig zu
sagen dass es Verluste dass die
russische Führung Verluste große
Verluste bei der Ausrüstung und bei dem
Personal in beiden Bereichen in Kauf
nimmt wir haben seit dem Beginn des
Krieges gesehen dass offenbar aus Sicht
der russischen Streitkräfte die Verluste
an Soldaten an Menschenleben keine Rolle
spielen der Oberbefehlshaber der
ukrainischen Streitkräfte salusini hat
jetzt die Zahl von 150.000 Verlust auf
russischer Seite gebracht es gibt andere
Zahlen aber es ist zumindest ein
Orientierungswert und das zeigt doch mal
wie menschenverachtend letztlich das
russische Vorgehen ist weil sie
keinerlei Rücksicht darauf nehmen wie
sie ihre Soldaten behandeln und welchen
Gefahren sie aussetzen also es zeigt
noch mal dass das russische vorgehen um
jeden Preis ist und offensichtlich auch
die politischen Ziele wichtiger sind als
die militärischen noch mal ich glaube
der Vergleich mit bachmut ist da
wirklich hilfreich denn bachmut die
Schlacht GEG mehrere Monate unter enorm
hohen Verlusten m und im Endeffekt ist
dann eine komplett zerstörte Stadt
erobert worden also es zeigt dass es von
russischer Seite ohne Rücksicht auf die
eigenen Soldaten dieser Krieg geführt
wird Frau major wir wollen jetzt noch
einmal gerne den Blick in die Ostukraine
richten und zwar in die Stadt kupjansk
da war unser Reporter nämlich heute
unterwegs und die Stadt gerätt nämlich
aktuell massiv unter russischen Beschuss
wir sprechen gleich noch mal miteinander
dann über die ukrainische Gegenoffensive
und auch die internationale
Unterstützung dafür vielen Dank erstmal
für den Moment und wie gesagt wir
schalten jetzt einmal zu meinem Kollegen
daran Dara Hassan Sade Dara du bist
jetzt gerade in rakif warst aber wie
gesagt heute in kupjansk unterwegs in
der Stadt die nur wenige Kilometer von
der Front entfernt liegt wie hast du die
Situation vor Ort
erlebt es war ausgesprochen ruhig wir
sind heute morgen ganz früh losgefahren
sind 120 km von hier von rakiv und dort
zu drehen wir waren mit einem
ukrainischen Offizier verabredet und als
wir in die Stadt reinfuhren
ähm roadblock war zwar alles ruhig aber
schon sehr angespannt man sieht die
Kriegsschäden von 600 Tagen Krieg die
Straßen sind leer aber sehr sauber
gefegt es Leben von 65 000 Menschen nur
noch so 5 6000 Zivilisten dort die
Gesichter waren versteinert ähm sie war
freudlos ähm auch von den Soldaten hat
man eine gewisse Anspannung gespürt es
waren auch gar nicht so viele Soldaten
auf den Straßen zu sehen es war zwar
jede Kreuzung besetzt die die Positionen
der ukrainischen Soldaten die sind
weiter vorgelagert wir waren mit dem
Offizier auf einer Anhöhe von dem man
weit blicken kann bis zum Horizont und
dort am Horizont ist schon Russland dort
ist die Grenze
die russischen Stellungen die ersten
sind allerdings deutlich näher am
Stadtgebiet so 7 km in der Zeit wo wir
da waren gab es vier Einschläge von
Artillerie die allerdings auch auf die
vorgelagerten Stellungen der Ukrainer
gerichtet waren die Stadt befindet sich
in einem Zustand würde ich beschreiben
auch nach dem Gesprächen mit dem
Bürgermeister
sie wissen wie es bachmut ergangen ist
und was in aufdka zurzeit stattfindet
und die Truppen Zusammenführung auf der
russischen Seite lassen vermuten dass
auch hier eine Großoffensive gestartet
werden soll Dara wir bekommen ganz viele
Kommentare und Fragen bei Youtube viele
gehen in die Richtung inwiefern der
Krieg im Nahen Osten jetzt den Krieg in
der Ukraine möglicherweise überschattet
hast du bei deinem Besuch jetzt in
dieser Stadt davon
etwas mitbekommen ist das möglicherweise
sie die Sorge der Menschen dort dass sie
eben da ein Stück weit nicht in
Vergessenheit geraten aber dass der die
öffentliche Aufmerksamkeit im Moment
woanders
liegt das ist ein Thema was man hier in
der Großstadt khakiv diskutieren kann
aber dort in unmittelbarer Frontnähe in
einer Stadt die letztes Jahr erleben
musste wie russische Truppen sie erobert
hat die dann von der ukrainischen Armee
zurückerobert wurde und nun trotzdem die
russischen Soldaten vor der vor den
Stadttoren hat ist das absolut gar kein
Thema das beschäftigt die Leute nicht
was die Leute beschäftigt ist
was passiert
in den nächsten Tagen was passiert
heute im Schnitt gibt es auf das größere
Stadtgebiet in den letzten sage ich mal
zwei Wochen so 30 Einschläge von
russischer
Artillerie der Offizier erklärte mir
dass der drohenkampf sehr entscheidend
ist die ukrainische Armee hat eine
deutliche Überlegenheit bei kamikaz
drohen und eine Unterlegenheit bei
aufklärungsdrohen die allerdings für das
ausspelen für Ziele der Artillerie sehr
wichtig ist und von daher schon ein
deutliches Problem
darstellen ich habe es gerade schon mal
gesagt die Front ist von kupjansk
ungefähr nur 7 km entfernt was macht die
Kämpfe dort aktuell so
schwierig es ist
zum einen das Hinterland das habe ich ja
eben beschrieben die russische Grenze
ist nur 20 km
entfernt und von dort kann natürlich
immer Nachschub geliefert werden ähm das
nächste ist das Land ist sehr flach
kobjansk selber ist auf einer Anhöhe
aber und von daher auch
zu verteidigen allerdings will man ja
als Ukrainisch von der ukrainischen
Seite her genau das verhindern dass
überhaupt die Kämpfe in die Stadt
getragen werden und in
Artillerie Reichweite wo Russland
deutlich überlegen ist ist die Stadt und
auch die russische die ukrainischen
Stellungen alle
mal wir haben jetzt gerade auch schon
von Frau maor auch schon gehört und ich
habe es auch gesagt Russland zieht seine
Truppen gerade beidifka zusammen 40.000
Soldaten sollen es sein und nimmt dabei
offenbar hohe menschliche Verluste auch
in Kauf welche Informationen hast du
dazu wir hatten heute eine Nachricht
bekommen von einem Soldaten den wir
schon länger kannten kennen und der nach
adivka verlegt wurde und der schildert
genau das was vorhin in dem Beitrag so
angesprochen wurden aus seiner
Sicht aus seiner Stellung heraus
wellenartige Angriffe die abgewehrt
werden und äh bevor die
ähm bevor man wieder in die Rotation
kommt das heißt dass man die vorderste
Linie verlässt und sich hinten etwas
hinter der Kampflinie etwas entspannen
kann kommt schon die nächste
Angriffswelle und
ähm vor Ort wenn man im Schützengraben
steht an seiner Position hat er gesagt
verliert man dann schon auch den
Überblick wie viele das sind und ähm wie
hoch und groß die Übermacht ist aber sie
ist anscheinend nicht so dass es zur
entscheidenden gewinnen auf russischer
Seite kam und
die Verluste sind müssen enorm sein die
dort
auf russischer Seite zurzeit
stattfinden wir haben jetzt gestern aus
Kiev von den schwersten den stärksten
russischen Angriffen seit Jahresbeginn
gehört auf über 100 Orte in der Ukraine
wie ist dieser diese Meldung deineer
Einschätzung nach einzuordnen
was ähm gesagt wurde ist nicht falsch es
wurden 118 Orte angegriffen in zehn
verschiedenen Provinzen ähm das waren
abererdings alles Provinzen die
Frontlinien haben und die Orte waren wie
z.B nicopol oder Cherson immer schon in
artillerieeuer und dieser
dieser Beschuss findet permanent statt
es ist jetzt nicht zu vergleichen mit
Angriffen wo
m mehr mehrere Marschflugkörper
abgeschossen werden die dann die
Luftabwehr über der Ukraine überfordern
wie die dann zu Treffern führten wie wir
es in Kiev erlebt hatten letztes Jahr im
Winter oder auch jetzt dem Sommer als
Odessa das große Ziel war nachdem das
getreideabkommen aufgekündigt wurde es
ist
faktisch bestimmt nicht falsch aber man
darf es nicht mit diesen großen
Luftangriffen vergleichen die ähm ab
schon auch schon stattgefunden
haben danke dir für diese Eindrücke und
Einschätzung daran hassanad live aus
rakiv danke schön ja soweit die
Eindrücke von meinem Kollegen von Vorort
wir wollen jetzt noch mal über die
Kämpfe insgesamt sprechen und über die
ukrainische Gegenoffensive da hat man in
den vergangenen Wochen ja immer wieder
gehört die sei hinter den Erwartungen
zurückgeblieben vor allem was
Geländegewinne angeht nein sagt die sagt
Claudia major diese Analyse greift zu
kurz es gibt durchaus Erfolge welche das
sind das will ich jetzt mit ihr
besprechen hallo noch mal nach Berlin
Frau major ich grüße Sie also wir sehen
diese Bilder von heftigen Kämpfen die
sowohl von der russischen als auch von
der ukrainischen Seite veröffentlicht
werden wenn wir mal das große Bild
betrachten wo steht dieser Krieg iher
Einschätzung nach aktuell also wenn wir
das große Bild betrachten dann müssen
wir natürlich sagen dass die ukrainische
Offensive das Ziel nicht erreicht hat
die russische Landbrücke zu durchbrechen
bis zum asofschen Meer durchzubrechen
und die russische Besatzung zu teilen
und damit mehr Druck auf die krimme
auszuüben das ist nicht gelungen das
heißt das Ziel wirklich einen Durchbruch
zu schaffen das hat nicht geklappt aber
natürlich gab es trotzdem auf Seiten der
Ukraine Erfolge und besonders wichtig
ist dabei dass es ihr gelungen ist Druck
auf die Krim auszuüben also es gab
systematische Angriffe auf die Krim auch
mit den britischen stormshadow und den
französischen skalalp wo sie die
Luftverteidigung ausgeschaltet haben es
gab einen großen Angriff auf das
Hauptquartier der Schwarzmeerflotte und
es ist der Ukraine tatsächlich damit
auch gelungen wieder so viel Kontrolle
über das Schwarze Meer herzustellen dass
die getreideschiffe wieder ablegen
konnten und deswegen finde ich es
wichtig so ein bisschen zu
differenzieren zwar ist das
übergeordnete Ziel der Offensive
gescheitt also der Durchbruch zum
asofschen Meer ist nicht gelungen aber
es gab trotzdem ukrainische
fortschrittte
der Druck auf die Krim der ausgeübt
worden ist die Zerstörung von
gefechtsständen von Logistikzentren und
anderen wichtigen Zielen hinter den
russischen Linien und es ist in an
einigen Teilen gelungen tatsächlich die
russischen Minenfelder und
Befestigungsanlagen zu durchbrechen
deswegen finde ich das ist etwas etwas
differenzierter zu betrachten also der
große Erfolg nicht der große Durchbruch
nicht aber kleinere Erfolge und das
deckt sich letztlich mit dem was auch
der ukrainische Generalstabschef also
der höchste ukrainische Militär
saluschni jetzt in dem Interview
Economist gesagt hat dass er sagte ja
die die wir sind in einem Stellungskrieg
de facto wo keiner der beiden Seiten
einen richtig großen Durchbruch schafft
ja Frau major lassen sie uns da gerne in
das Interview was jetzt gerade
angesprochen haben wir haben dazu auch
ein Zitat Vorliegen von Herrn salusni
lassen sie uns da gerne einmal kurz
gemeinsam reinschauen und zwar hat Herr
salusni gesagt ein Stellungskrieg ist
ein langwierriiger Krieg der enorme
Risiken für die Streitkräfte und den
ukra ischen Staat BGT wenn die Ukraine
dieser Falle entkommen will brauchen wir
all diese Dinge Luftüberlegenheit stark
verbesserte Fähigkeiten zur
elektronischen Kriegsführung und zur
artillerieaufklärung neue Technologie
zur minensprengung und die Fähigkeit
mehr Reservisten zu mobilisieren und
auszubilden wenn wir jetzt auf diesen
Stellungskrieg er hat es auch genannt
schauen wie würde ein solcher
Stellungskrieg von dem er hier warnt
aussehen wie könnte der aussehen
keiner der beiden Seiten weder Russland
noch die Ukraine signifikante
Fortschritte machen also wir haben
anfangs über über den Kampf um afdevka
gesprochen wo die Russen versuchen mit
voller Macht anzugreifen und das
passiert trotzdem nicht so richtig viel
das heißt keine der beiden Seiten machen
enorme Fortschritte und das heißt dass
auf der strategischen Ebene weder
Russland noch die Ukraine das in einen
Vorteil umwandeln können saluschni nimmt
auch das Beispiel des Ersten Weltkrieges
was wir alle vor Augen haben mit den mit
den jahrelangen
äh kämpfen in den
ähm also den jahrelangen
stellungskrämpfen im Ersten Weltkrieg
und rekuriert darauf und sagt im
Endeffekt was uns droht ist dass wir in
ein vergleichbares Szenario kommen wo
sich wirklich lange nichts bewegt und in
einem solchen Szenario wo sich nicht
richtig viel bewegt ist die Ukraine
langfristig eindeutig unterlegen weil
sie langfristig diesen diesen Nachschub
an an Personal an Ausrüstung an Munition
nicht leisten kann und das ist die große
Warnung die saluschni in Raum stellt
Stellungskrieg nutzt im Endeffekt
Russland und deswegen muss die Ukraine
und müssen die westlichen
unterstützerstaaten für die Ukraine
überlegen wie sie da rauskommen können
und das ist die Empfehlung die er am
Ende macht und die Empfehlung kann man
zusammenfassen und kann sagen neue
Technologien Kreativität und Innovation
das sind die Möglichkeiten die er sieht
um dieses P um diesen Stillstand zu
überwinden und da wieder
rauszukommen lassen Sie uns über die
internationale Unterstützung gleich
gerne noch einmal sprechen ich würde
gerne eine Frage die wir bekommen haben
bei Youtube einmal an Sie weitergeben
und zwar fragt Neft Schmidt sehen sie
noch eine Chance dass die Ukraine in
absehbarer Zeit größere Teile des von
Russland besetzten Territoriums
zurückerobern
kann wenn es bei den Bedingungen bleibt
die wir jetzt haben was die militärische
finanzielle politische Unterstützung
angeht sehe ich gerade wenig Hoffnung
darauf dass der Ukraine ist dass es der
Ukraine gelingt wirklich signifikante
Fortschritte zu machen wir reden immer
sehr viel von Unterstützung as long as
takes also solange wie es notwendig ist
die Ukraine zu unterstützen ich glaube
dass das nicht ganz richtig ist ich
glaube wir müssen eher sagen so viel wie
die Ukraine wirklich braucht so viel
solangee müssen wir Sie unterstützen
also man muss viel mehr überlegen ob die
qualitative und quantitative
Unterstützung genug ist und deswegen
Antwort auf die Frage nein momentan sehe
ich das nicht wenn man die Ukraine in
die Lage versetzen will
muss man die Quantität und die Qualität
der Unterstützung signifikant verändern
mhm dazu passt sehr gut die Frage von
Buddy bei Youtube wie kann der Westen
ist denn erreichen die Ukraine so zu
unterstützen dass sie sich verteidigen
kann und Putin aus der Ukraine abzieht
gibt es ist diese gibt es diese Option
überhaupt realistisch ist diese Option
überhaupt realistisch ja man kann sich
an dem orientieren was saluschni gesagt
hat sie haben das ja eben eingeblendet
das war Luftüberlegenheit das war
elektronische Kriegführung das war
artiller
Aufklärung das war minenbekämpfung und
bessere Ausbildung von Personal und in
fast allen diesen Bereichen können die
westlichen Staaten besser und mehr
unterstützen und da kann Deutschland wer
machen da können die anderen westlichen
unterstützerstaat mehr machen aber ich
glaube wir müssen immer sagen es gibt
nicht dieses eine Wundermittel sondern
das ist ein Paket und diese fünf
Elemente die S luschni genannt hat
werden dabei entscheidend sein also wie
kann man beispielsweise auch bei der
Ausbildung besser helfen wie kann man
bei der Luftüberlegenheit helfen sind ja
alles Elemente wo wir also wo die
westlichen Staaten militärisch
unterstützen können es gibt jetzt die
ziemlich aktuelle Meldungen und zwar
plant die beiden Regierung am Freitag
ein militärpaket in Höhe von 425
Millionen US-Dollar für die Ukraine
anzukündigen das Paket umfasst offenbar
Munition für abwehrdrohnen das sagten
zwei us-beamte am Donnerstag es wurde
jetzt ja in den vergangenen Monaten auch
viel wenn wir auch auf aus liefer auf
Lieferung aus Deutschland schauen über
den marschlugkörper Taurus diskutiert
die ich habe es gerade schon mal gesagt
die öffentliche Aufmerksamkeit liegt ja
gerade vor allem auf dem Krieg im Nahen
Osten Bundeskanzler Scholz will Taurus
weiterhin nicht liefern ist sozusagen
die Verschiebung der öffentlichen
Aufmerksamkeit möglicherweise gerade
vielleicht ein günstiger Zeitpunkt wenn
man das so nennen kann um dieses
Waffensystem doch an die Ukraine zu
liefern wie schätzen Sie das
ein ich finde es einfach sehr gut wenn
wenn diese Entscheidung jetzt getroffen
werden würde denn alle Gründe die gegen
eine Lieferung von Taurus sprechen sind
abgeräumt worden also wir wissen
mittlerweile dass es kein
bundeswehrmandat braucht dass keine
Bundeswehrsoldaten vor Ort benötigt
werden wir wissen dass man die
Reichweite so einstellen kann oder so
juristisch mit den ukrainischen
Streitkräften oder der ukrainischen
Regierung vereinbarn kann dass sie nicht
auf russisches Territorium zielen kann
wir haben bei der Lieferung der
französischen und der BR Bons gesehen
dass es zu keiner weiteren Eskalation
kommt das heißt all die rationalen
Gründe die man natürlich besonden
überdenken muss die sind abgeräumt es
bleibt also eine politische Entscheidung
und ich hoffe dass sie jetzt getroffen
wird weil man merkt dass es der Ukraine
helfen kann es ist kein gamechanger kein
einziges Waffensystem allein ist ein
gamechanger aber in dem Paket wäre es
für die Ukraine sehr hilfreich und es
wäre ein klares Signal dass man die
Ukraine auch langfristig unterstützen
möchte denn das ist letztlich die Frage
kriegt die Ukrainer langfristig die
politische militärische finanzielle
humanitäre Unterstützung die sie braucht
um durchhalten zu können man sagte immer
dass ein Krieg sagen zumindest die
Militärs immer auch ein Test von von
Wille und von Logistik und Unterstützung
ist also der der länger durchhält der
den längeren Atem hat unterstützt wird
den Krieg für sich entscheiden können
hoffentlich und Russland spielt wir
hatten das vorher abgesprochen russland
hofft letztlich dass es länger durchhält
weil es weil die Ukraine politisch
militärisch nicht schafft weil die
westliche Unterstützung nachlässt und
deswegen wäre es wichtig jetzt noch mal
ganz klar zu sagen gerade wenn die
Situation für die Ukraine so schwierig
ist dass die westlichen
unterstützerstaaten stark an ihrer Seite
stehen ein Satz noch wenn ich sagen darf
weil es eben auch im
sicherheitspolitischen Interesse der
Europäer ist eine souveräne freie
Ukraine unabhängige Ukraine ist im
sicherheitspolitischen Interesse im
Interesse der der Stabilität und
Sicherheit in Europa und damit auch für
Deutschland das sollten wir immer wieder
immer wieder Bedenken Frau major dann
lassen Sie uns gerne abschließend noch
einmal den Blick nach vorne richten auf
die kommenden Monate Herbst und
Wintermonate die jetzt
bevorstehen was kommt da auf die
Menschen in der Ukraine zu droht
möglicherweise wieder eine neue
winterwelle mit Angriffen auf die zivile
Infrastruktur was Putin genau vorhat
wissen wir natürlich nicht aber viel
deutet darauf hin dass sich die Ukraine
wie auch im letzten Jahr auf massive
Schläge einstellen muss wir haben im
letzten Jahr systematische
ähm Anschläge oder systematische
Angriffe auf die zivile Infrastruktur
gesehen also zivile Infrastruktur ist
alles das was die Zivilisten zum Leben
brauchen vom Krankenhaus bis zum
Wasserwerk und wir haben im letzten
Winter gesehen dass Russland das
systematisch gemacht hat und das heißt
de facto dass es der Versuch war der
Zivilbevölkerung die Lebensgrundlagen zu
entziehen wenn sie im Winter keinen
Strom haben Ken Wasser keine Heizung
haben entzieht man ihn die
Lebensgrundlagen und das kann man auch
wenn man es ganz brutal formuliert als
eine
entvölkerungsstrategie verstehen also
dass Russland de facto die
Zivilbevölkerung damit zwingen will das
Land zu
verlassen zweiter Punkt dass sie damit
die Ukraine de facto in den
wirtschaftlichen Ruinen bombardieren
wollen und wir sehen das haben wir im
letzten Winter bei diesen Angriffen
gerade auf die Zivilbevölkerung gesehen
wie wenig Russland auf das humanitäre
Völkerrecht wertlet
und wie wenig es Rücksicht gerade auf
die Zivilbevölkerung NMT sondern im
Gegenteil dass die Angriffe auf die
Zivilbevölkerung Teil der russischen
Kriegsstrategie sind und wie gesagt
viele sollte darauf hin dass wir eine
solche Angriffswelle
in diesem Winter noch mal sehen werden
weil Russland letztlich seine
Kriegsziele nicht verändert hat das
sieht man in den öffentlichen
Positionierungen von Putin oder auch von
anderen Regierungsvertretern Russland
verfolgt immer noch das Ziel die Ukraine
als eigenständigen souveränen Staat
auszulöschen und deswegen steht uns
sicherlich ein sehr oder der Ukraine
nicht uns der Ukraine ein sehr
schwieriger Winter bevor Frau major
vielen Dank für Ihre Einschätzung und
die Fragen die Antworten auf meine
Fragen heute abend Claudia major
Sicherheits und militärexertin bei der
Stiftung Wissenschaft und Politik in
Berlin vielen Dank sehr gerne soweit
unser ZDF heute live mit dem Ukraine
Update aktuelle Meldung an Live Ticker
und Analysen findet ihr wie immer in der
ZDF heute App danke für eure Fragen
danke fürs zuschauen und bis zum
nächsten
Mal